we're here with sonia manzour
hello hi sonia hi atlas thanks for
coming on the program
thank you for inviting me i'm really
excited for this likewise
yeah we're still at bentino massaro's
shift into permanent alignment
retreat in costa rica
been getting the opportunity to meet
epic people i'm really excited for you
guys to
hear about sonia's journey and what
she's currently doing
to catalyze awakening and alignment
all right sonia let's start with your
spiritual journey how did you pick up
spirituality
let's talk about that okay so
spirituality has always been a part of
my life
my context
riley who we're going to have on the
show soon is currently
back and yeah what's up
boom i love it yeah jordan popped in
also to corey's show so it's so fun i
love it
yeah yeah i love it i love it um
all right so yeah so the spiritual
journey let's do it okay yeah so
spirituality has always been part of my
container
um i was born to enter a muslim family
and
then went to a catholic school after
that
that taught advaita vedanta meditation
and other techniques
yeah and then as i grew older
i started dating a young man
that was a jehovah's witness and so i've
always felt
held by different communities and always
had an inclination towards the spiritual
paradigms
that were here existing but also like an
unwillingness or a resistance towards
committing myself or my identity to
to any of them so i've stayed pretty
open and pretty playful with all of it
um when i was 14 though i did go through
a moment where i was like i don't know i
don't know about any of this actually
um but then
all this happened pre-14 no okay yeah so
the timeline's a little off but
i was by by the time i was 14 i was at
the school
it's called snape james independent
school in london
and it was epic because it had space for
so many different faiths
and so many different paradigms and ways
of believing or having faith
yeah um and yeah
yeah yeah a lot of a lot of i think it
was triggering for a lot of the
girls and boys at the school but i don't
know for some reason it felt great for
me and that's where obviously the
the the concept of oneness was
introduced there boom
yeah that's really young that's great
yeah yeah yeah that's great yeah
um and that felt horrifying in in its
own little way
you know just being having a teacher
speak to you about the fact that
everything is one even though i wasn't
necessarily
i couldn't conceive that as i was still
a person in the material world
um but yeah i still felt it very
strongly
um felt the resonance with it but then
had this moment whilst i was still at
the school
um when i was 14 where i disbelieved
i just went through a phase of just
being like i don't know i don't i don't
believe in any of this
i'm not seeing the hard proof you know
um i'm not really experientially
feeling any of it and so then what
happened was i was on an escalator
um with a friend of mine and
i what feels like i received a download
and i just
turned to her and i i i said to her
have you heard about the collective
conscious collective consciousness
um and she looked at me as if something
strange was going on and but for me
we came through with conviction you know
it came through with conviction and it
was beautiful that was happening
happening on an escalator
which i mean now i've reflected upon as
a beautiful
metaphor yeah um yeah oh that's so cool
yeah
yeah it was really cool that's me i
actually got an escalator so cool
but then i i kind of i didn't integrate
that it happened and it was beautiful
and i felt extremely
vast in this moment of escalation
and and then yeah and then
went back into my normal school day life
and um
and then met this young man um and
was shown the jehovah's witness
community
and they get a lot of um bad press
but my experience in that um
was was beautiful i felt a lot of love
i felt the understanding for why the
community is so tightly knit
i saw a lot of support um
and so there was a lot of beauty in
faith not to say that there isn't
necessarily a shadow side i don't know
um but still i didn't find myself
committed to that although i found it as
you
use the word nectaris you know yeah
yesterday but so i found it nectaris
something about it was nectarist but
then that relationship ended and
i continued um and went to berlin and
then
just started partying and then i guess i
found god in drugs
so this is around 18 which moved now i
know so in
i moved to berlin when i was in my very
early 20s
but for university i studied product
design and at that point i was just
materialistic did you say pottery
product design oh product design yeah
okay
interesting yeah okay yeah also
interesting because it's interaction
yeah yeah yeah it's really good to have
a tech an entrepreneurial
addition to one's world view along with
spirituality yeah it's really good
yeah and so then i found myself in
berlin and was just really into
losing myself and
took all the party drugs and all the
psychedelics and whatever
was necessary for for that moment and
did feel expansion through that and did
have epic realizations through that and
i'm extremely grateful for that process
and for
being taught by these substances and not
just the substances but also the people
on the substances you know that was that
that was an epic resonance totally
and heart opening
but still after that i started to start
i started to feel a lot of anxiety
which was unexpected i thought okay my
identity is now here i planted my
identity firmly in the in the party
scene nightlife
um and what i wanted was to just
continue with that but when i was in the
line for clubs i would feel anxiety
and i started to perceive a little bit
more of what was going on but i was
so uncomfortable with it so i was trying
to contract myself
more and stay in what i knew
as my paradigm um and so i'd go into the
club and just
take whatever and try and relieve
some of whatever was actually happening
um until i got to the point where i just
couldn't even
stand in the line because whatever was
happening was
more than a party drug could fill or
could
cure or could
help me resist yeah and then the dark
night happened
and it felt like an it a come down from
all of the partying that i'd done before
but in this dark night
i felt a lot of the expectations i felt
a lot of the falsehoods that i've been
carrying i felt a lot of
um what i thought i was and what i was
expected to be
i felt the weight of that and i could
also
acknowledge that that that was no longer
resonating but i didn't see a way out
um and so it became really really dark
and in that darkness there was
a portal into mysticism dope
i love this yeah yeah which i was also
not prepared for
um i didn't i didn't at that point have
a paradigm to hold that experience
but i was experiencing entities
and but of of the same
vibration that i was in and that were
feeding off of
fear and so i was in a lot of resistance
and i was in a lot of fear
in my waking state i could sense them
you know
not see them but i could sense them or
at least i was
creating them i can't be certain of what
was happening but it was
mystical as can i swear of course [ __ ]
it was
mystical as [ __ ] this goes far it was
mystical it's fun
and um yeah but then i was afraid
um and
at some point in that depression or in
that darkness
briefly it's important to also mention
that once we gain
enough awareness as the creator we
recognize that we actually
create ted that scenario the whole
paradigm
for awakening for ourselves yes and at
that time sometimes it's really hard for
us to
because we're not yet at the stage of
recognizing ourselves as the creator we
think it's
an external it's another if there's a
sep there's a separation it's something
else that is doing it but it's actually
me doing it me the creator
doing it to myself in this expression
so that i can awaken to my true nature
pierce the veilless veil
find myself through the hiding i
provided myself with this catalyst
i love that what a beautiful way to say
it perfect
yes um we provide ourselves with the
catalyst
yeah boom yeah
so i found myself in this in this
mystical space and i would walk into
a bars or wherever and i felt like i
could
affect a room but but i
could couldn't affect it positively at
that point i wasn't i couldn't feel my
own light
i felt so heavy and so low vibe that
when i walked in i felt like i had that
kind of an influence and i was seeing it
happen you know it was
feeling and seeing the room dark and as
i was in in the space and then i was
like okay i can't take myself into
spaces
um because i'm having this kind of an
impact so i've got to isolate
and then in the isolation what happened
was
what i then experienced is the most
terrifying thing um i developed
a psychosis or
i would say that it felt like
schizophrenia what i would say is
schizophrenia i don't know for sure but
i could
hear entities no not just sense them i
could hear them
in my waking state and when i would go
to sleep i started experiencing
sleep paralysis which is an equally
terrifying state have you you have
you've explored sleep sleeper
yeah yeah for sure terrifying yeah for
sure terrifying
especially having no context you know
and um the beautiful thing about this
is is that earlier that year
one of my closest friends um developed
paranoid schizophrenia or went in deep
into psychosis
and he was put away for it and i felt a
lot of guilt for that
and i felt a lot of loss
in that and a lot of grief and on some
level
created a mini version of what he had
gone through for myself
what now looking back on it a rival
style you know
it feels like yeah that i needed his
experience
and then i created the experience that i
required in order to be able to connect
to that kind of
a catalyst perfect yeah and it's a very
specific kind of catalyst because it has
to do
in with the world of in the
materialistic paradigm
with the world of mental health you know
and so
that is the context for it out there yes
but in here it's actually a spiritual
emergence
yeah and it looks like a spiritual
emergency great way to put it no
yeah that's well that's what it felt
like it's interesting because in the
east
it's very much excited yeah it's like
applauded
this like expansion yeah to what the
west could
sometimes call mentally unstable
and then put people into pharmaceuticals
or into
psychiatric wards yes yeah it's a huge
civilizational
tweak that we must undistort yeah
absolutely because what was happening
was i was
becoming more perceptive i had
increased awareness and i did not know
how to translate my experiences i did
not know how to hold everything that i
was now
perceiving and all i wanted to do was to
contract my awareness again because that
felt safer
and so i was trying to suppress my
expansion
out of fear um and so i was also
translating all the things that i was
perceiving out of fear
so i was in a fear-based state creating
fearful projections translating them
fearfully and perpetuating this state
um but on the other side of it
on day three of it i popped
into a greater sense of awareness
and understanding and safety and
relaxation
and calmness but that's not to say that
i couldn't experience the contraction
still in the fear still
something happened and i was out here
you know but i could still feel this
wow yeah i could still feel this but it
felt
it felt not me you became more witnessy
or observery
to the frames that were moving along the
movie
yeah that's that's such a beautiful pop
it was
it was epic and it that is what
completely 180 my trajectory
completely 180 in a very slow way
because again i didn't have containers
so i started to try and build
myself a way to understand this and
that is when the love-based translation
started to filter through
because i also recognized as this pop
happened i was like oh
[ __ ] you are not that you know like i
you know yourself and you know yourself
as love
you've always known yourself as love
you've always known yourself as
connected and interconnected there's
always been this understanding
my whole entire childhood and life
before was set up so that i would always
be
in the stream of knowing that you know
and feeling that
and so that is that was my gift you know
that's the gift i gave myself in terms
of this incarnation was that i got to
experience the madness
but then i got to fall back into a
container also
of of oneness perfect and
a lot of people don't get to have that
they don't have that container to fall
back into
you know and so then they do go the
conventional route
in the current paradigm you know which
is to seek help and to get medicated and
to
to suppress like what i was trying to do
with family guy or with
smoking weed or with whatever whatever
and the weed actually was like
expanding me more it wasn't that it
wasn't the right thing but anyway
it was the perfect thing um
and then i realized okay you have
expectations
your experience experiencing yourself is
contracted you're not feeling
excited you're not feeling passionate
you're not feeling aligned at that word
i didn't have the word aligned at the
time i didn't have the word aligned and
so i decided okay drop everything
and reprogram yourself you've you've
created a lot of fear-based thinking
what happens what will happen
if you do something different and at
that moment i didn't know what i would
do different
um but i just want i knew i wanted to
break some patents because i could i
felt
unliberated i felt contracted in myself
and in my life
that i had created so i had created a
trap for myself
that i had to like an escape room i
created this great room for myself to
break out
perfect way to put it yeah each one of
us creates our own
little escape room as the creator
and then we undergo a process of
piercing that veilus veil and finding
our true nature
yeah and that's what's meant by the sufi
metaphysic wadat al-wujud the unity of
all finding because everybody has their
own unique
style of finding so you sum all of these
little
individuated styles of finding as the
one creator and it's like what a
most profound aphorism that that is and
so yeah you
describe your own little escape room
which
is different than their escape room and
mine and
many other people's and that's what's
beautiful is that you're going to have
your own little contraptions in your
escape room that are then going to
provide you with massive wisdoms in
service to other people because you've
been through them
yeah absolutely and that that was a
great learning
in fear or of fear and of contraction
and it also provided me with
compassion that i didn't have before um
for those kinds of experiences
you know these kinds of mystical
experiences that are taking place that
are
very much dismissed and labeled as just
you're going nuts
you know even though it does feel like
you're going nuts i was going nuts
um because you're communing with
infinity and nothingness
and god all at the same time and
it's indescribable and
so much of the time we take our
experience to
people that we shouldn't be taking our
experience to because then
they hit the gold out of our hands
yeah they're not trained to be able to
hold you in that they're not trained for
that
and it's not their fault it's just that
they they haven't had
that paradigm installed within them that
can that can
catch you as you are going through all
of this messiness in the washing machine
of
expansion you know and uh and it can be
really disconcerting to not
have a community to fall back on or a
worldview to fall back on or just a
paradigm
to fall back on and so that is what i
experienced
um even though i did have that pop and i
did have
something to catch me but i also was
able to identify that as unique
you know in my experience and so after
that i went into music
and was and i experienced what it meant
to not have expectations
and so i got to experience being in
flow because living a life full of
expectations
does not allow you to move in flow it
doesn't allow you
to to surrender into anything
because it's based around trying to
control outcomes
it's based around very contracted states
of being and of consciousness
and so yeah so the music
popped me out more there were lessons in
ego there and but still
had another pop out um and when the band
came to a close i
was like okay let's go online what is
this one online online look look look
look and i found creative consciousness
um which is a form of coaching
created by a man called mark steinberg a
german man
and it is a form of coaching that does
have a spiritual backdrop
container and it is very very open
because it does come from
a more non-dual place and so it it
includes
anyone's belief system it doesn't make
wrong anybody
you know um and that was the resonance
that i found with that form of coaching
and i didn't know what it was and i just
appreciate it you were also prepared for
it with
your st james st james yeah independent
school yeah
it was it was amazing to have that yeah
because you were prepared into
a lot of the oneness and non-duality
even when you were younger although you
may not have known you were doing it
right that kind of thing it's always
beautiful connecting those stuff
yeah yeah and so i
was at the i booked i just booked the
creative consciousness
um coaching session the first bit of it
and did the first bit of training and
was just hooked because
what is so sick about it is that it is
experiential
it is not like you're not sitting there
in in a class and what they're doing is
they're telling you a whole bunch of
stuff that you've got to write notes and
then you've got to hold that and that's
it you know
mark has designed this program that you
go there and you experience
stuff you have to experience and so the
whole entire program is based around
putting you
in challenging situations the whole
point of the program like an escape room
like an escape room but the container is
love and there is
there are people trained to hold you
there just like this just like this
but more accelerated
more experiential experiential too yeah
yeah it's cool
yeah it's so cool and so so give us an
example of some of the
activities the most triggering one was
on
was on day one and um so what mark made
us
do it was another trainer but it's his
design um it's
uh we were we were told to get in touch
with
anger that's that was the whole
intention of this exercise
was to know anger because
mark teaches that it is it is one of
those energies that has been made wrong
so much
you know and that we don't know how to
express it
we've been told that it is dangerous
we've been told that it is
violent we've been told that it is
whatever whatever you know any kind of
label around anger in general is a
negative one
and so that makes the whole entire
energy which is neither negative nor
positive wrong um which then leads
leads us to start installing suppressed
mechanisms within our being
you know and so that we don't get to
learn about that energy
we don't get to know ourselves with that
energy on that energy
functioning with that power source
and so the exercise i hope i'm allowed
to share it
and i will but it's the exercise
was you could also glaze over it
abstractly also just in case if that's
better
okay cool just whatever you feel is best
the exercise was
he created a situation a context
between two beings where one person
holds space
or provides the context or the reason
for why the other person has to start
embodying anger
and so you're awesome to embody anger
yeah
and it's pretty tricky it is it's really
tricky it is and it was on day one in a
room full of strangers you don't
oh yeah yeah and so
immediately he you're also being asked
to let go of your self-image you're
being asked to
like to get angry and to know yourself
as angry when you've never pushed anger
you know you may have been triggered and
had a rage outburst or whatever but
to keep going and keep going and keep
going that's the point of the exercise
it's to keep going
you know and keep going and keep going
until someone
stops you or until your your suppression
mechanism comes in
and then you get to know your
suppression mechanism so you see it
yeah you see what happens when you read
a
certain threshold of anger and how how
do you then
suppress it or allow it or use it
does it become destructive does it
become and then his that is all based on
knowing yourself
you have to be able to know it okay
because if you don't know it
it's part of your shadow and it will
just come out when you're triggered
you will be in a rage situation and then
you'll suppress it and then deny it ever
happened
this is probably a good place to hit a
tennis ball back because
i'm familiar with this type of exercise
it has also been taught by some of the
other people that have come on to our
show
i do see interesting
benefits in exploring
a breadth of emotional
states that also give you insight into
the suppression mechanisms
i find that really insightful yet
i also am
interested in the amount of people
that create scenarios like this
in terms of their knowledge of
the teachings of buddha or patanjali
because what happens is when you
undergo those mystic teachings
you basically watch anger arise
and then you see that you are not that
and then it disappears like a cloud or
like a wave on the ocean
right and what it does is over time it
basically
extinguishes the roots
of misery and suffering
and so in a sense
anger itself no longer arises
because you've done the work
how do you feel about that
yeah i mean beautifully put instead um
well the paths are many totally
and the end is one yeah and the end is
one
and for many people we're
here incarnated to know
the human experience and to
have a visceral experience of it and
then
and then often i feel like the people
are more likely to take a non-dual path
but it's very rare for someone to just
straight out of like school like bentino
did you know like
it's rare he's a he's a rare one you're
a rare one to just go for
the non-dual you know um but
first first to unblock the being
and then start making choices first to
know
yourself see oh [ __ ] i've got a trigger
there i'm blocked here
this is where i'm contracted this is the
expectation this is my mom's
all my mom's wishes this is how i'm
supposed to i was being trained to be in
service
you know like you realize how what kind
of what does the cage look like
that you're in you see the walls and
some of them are energetic
and some of them are physical and some
of them are just concepts
you know and so that that is the work
that so you would say creative
consciousness helps you see the scripts
the algorithms the cage
yeah okay the person consciousness the
body consciousness and it sort of helps
liberate you from those scripts and
cages absolutely
show you the bigger picture of the
escape room yeah it makes you take
responsibility for it
and that's that's the that's the other
powerful thing about it
um yeah is that mark's teacher was also
jiddu krishnamurthy
beautiful so he studied with
krishnamurthy in and uh
and so there is a lot of
the backdrop that is based in
liberating yourself and
being your own teacher you know
and so that is the that is why i feel
that the coaching that mark has created
is so powerful is because even when you
sit with a client
um there is a context that you have to
set for yourself
as a coach and the first one of the
first context is that your client is
already whole
boom yeah like perfection
perfecting yeah yeah
yeah and so there's that context
and then there's there's the other
context um
which is that you are being coached by
your client
you know and then there's a third
context
which is that well you've got to check
whether or not you have an agenda
because you cannot be a coach
if you have an agenda yeah that's to
purify where you're coming from
precisely
yeah precisely and so there's a protocol
that you've got to go through to check
yourself before you sit with any client
um yeah and and when you
when you sit with that protocol you're
just like oh this is totally based on
non-duality this protocol it's totally
trying to purify where i'm coming from
perfect you know yeah and so i trained
in that
and um but then okay and then started
working
um slowly worked on myself
worked in the field worked on myself
worked in the field and
purified where i was coming from
understood things about self-worth and
value and a lot of different things were
started to shift as i went down that
path um
but then i realized the type of client
that i was attracting
which was really interesting and that
happened for me in order for me to be
able to see what is happening in the
materialistic paradigm
which is exactly what we spoke about
earlier in this conversation
you know that people are going through
awakenings without having
a container with
all right excellent so there was a
little bit of a
streaming wi-fi issue but we are back
it was actually at a perfect moment with
the transition
yeah okay fair to say we should probably
visualize this also for people
so
if you watch some of the content on our
channel
we've done a dissemination of the law of
one the
seven densities and bentino has as well
so
highly recommend checking those out and
what you'll see in them is you'll see
that the in the one infinite creator
expressing itself via this creation to
explore itself and play
that where we're currently at is around
this third
density of evolution where it's very
humans in a civilization
where you can create a gradient in terms
of
more egoic levels of consciousness to
more enlightened levels of consciousness
and egoic levels of consciousness
typically you already know
how they behave but you can think about
it like a dirtier mirror
and that when you go from third to what
is called fourth density fourth density
is about being in service to
others rather than being in service to
yourself
and so you really get this love
that's just channeling through to
express
itself to be in service to other people
so what
sonia is talking about and what bentino
was talking about yesterday with
igniting this global awakening
in a very decentralized way
is that we specifically have to become
shepherds for
the third to fourth density
and so let's have sonia explain to us
sort of the container the maximal
optimization for the awakening
of people from third to fourth density
because there are so many different
escape rooms yeah right and styles
all right looks like we're back again
okay
thanks for letting us know in the
comments we love you all very much
thanks for being here super appreciate
you
so we've had several people come onto
the show
and talk about sort of the optimization
of that third to fourth
container one of the keys that we found
is that the one-on-one
mentorship is mission critical so it's
like
pairing escape rooms similarities
with each other like someone that's
already at fourth
density that's went through a similar
escape room as someone that's shifting
from third to fourth
is a great mentor and so it's linking
people up like that
so how do you feel about that and other
strategies to optimize the container for
third to fourth
well sorry that was like real close
yeah um i agree with that
um and i think that
there that we can lean into resonance
also
the law of resonance and the reason i
say that is because
again i've attracted a very particular
kind of client and the client that i
attract
is going through has been going through
um what would look like a mental health
crisis
um and that can be anything from
suicide dull ideation or attempts
all the way through to um
psychosis you know or or bipolar or
severe depression or whatever it may be
um yeah
yeah but also very very teaching part of
the collective
um yeah and they're exploring something
you know they're exploring
um darkness and again being in that
place
is not a negative polarization but it is
a um you ever heard the aphorism the
brighter the flame the deeper the shadow
i haven't that's a good one huh yeah
yeah you young obviously says that the
roots have to
reach hell for the flowers to branches
to reach heaven so
there are many different ways to say
this one but i do like the brighter the
flame the deeper the shadow
yeah so people unknowingly are in this
like sonu list this buffet of darkness
options
and that those greatest traumas serve as
these greatest treasures
yeah yeah yes yes and um again
not to disclose much information but i
had a client
recently um attempt to take her life
and she has
been able to distill such wisdom from
that perhaps we should have there should
be a trigger warning
on this i don't know but that that is
that it's pretty profound though
yes i i was also suicidal i think did
you
say that you have had you didn't
throughout your life
many people here have had yeah
but what she distilled from that was the
understanding of liberation
perfect you know and before that the
the paradigm wasn't there she hadn't
installed it within herself
you know right at that point in time it
was just a lot of talk
um but she was missing the experience
and so that was her catalyst
which she created for herself and um
that also taught me to be unattached
in order to be of service i cannot be of
service if i'm attached to anyone's
outcome
perfect because then i'm coming from
somewhere impure within me
perfect you know and but that was the
most depthful
um client experience that i'd had
but one that has been my just
the most gift-giving um because of the
depth
of darkness and so that is who i attract
but in this
in this learning um of my
experience is that we don't have a
worldview to catch a lot of people that
are waking up
that there isn't widely
accepted and understood um
perspective on what we're calling mental
health issues
and that's not to say that that the
mental health field
is wrong you know but it's just that
there is more
that there are more paradigms to infuse
into it
you know and absolutely yeah
yeah like all of non-duality yeah like
all of it exactly
exactly and so this is all i feel
centerless
and it's like oh my gosh rush into the
hospital no it's like
hey wait a second whoa you might be
awakening
yeah yeah the my person consciousness
might be dissolving
we you might be awakening we have a
great container set up for you to
explore that
yeah yeah that's like future
i think we're approaching dsm-6 is the
next one what is dsm-6
the diagnostic statistic manual for
psychological
psychiatric evolution evaluation
yeah it's like the sixth iteration i
think it's published every seven years
or something and so it has basically all
of the different
like psychologists around the planet and
even neuroscientists and i think
physicians and
psychiatrists end up
creating this sort of set very kind of
centralized codified but also
decentralized
hierarchy but also hierarchy approach to
understanding mental health and illness
and it's just interesting to think about
how many of them
have ever experienced anything outside
of
their own finite body consciousness yeah
because if they've never
even went beyond that and then they're
making this that's part of the reason
so yeah basically incorporate a lot of
the non-dual
awakening and alignment to the
modern sort of cutting-edge
psychiatric evaluation exactly yeah
exactly because at the moment
um what what it feels like to me is that
a lot of
um a very key
players uh are are locked up at the
moment you know
and are unaware
that what they're going through is a
very profound shift
um that is of planetary relevance
you know um that's right and collective
relevance
um and it is just really unfortunate
that there isn't
this understanding within the within the
mental health community and if there is
it's just not
expressed for whatever reason um and
furthermore the the spaces that these um
these individuals are taken to are not
places of healing
you know so they don't promote the
the understanding or the deepening of um
their own alignment and expansion
but in fact support a deeper deepening
in contracted states
so let's say that if we were to play and
identify the core
ways to assist in the third to fourth
density container building for people's
awakenings
one of the components which we've both
agreed on so far is the style of
one-on-one mentorship with people with
similar escape rooms yes
okay what would be other containers
or processes that you found
or that we can find together
well other containers what comes up when
you when you when you ask that
is to create spaces that
provide healing actually
um for for
those that have that have
undergone psychological trauma
is what it will be experienced as by
that individuated
person consciousness and
what that looks like is manifold i think
that there isn't just one way
because there are infinite again
infinite expressions of awakening so
we've also got to approach this in a
more kind of infinite
um yeah manner you know and so
what would your ideal space look like
for someone with that's experiencing
person consciousness and psychological
trauma
that's undergoing awakening expansion as
well as
suffering what would be a way
would there be something digital that i
would
potentially sign up for that would then
send me some more physical where there
would be that's that's a cool concept i
didn't think of that i'm not i don't
really go into the the technological
stuff you did product design though
i did do product design but i was like
designing working you know
second density first density object
right but okay so you
um that is a great that is a great idea
we yeah
yeah yeah just playing coming up with
this stuff and then now
implementing it yeah guys also post in
the comments what do you think like
well what kind of a healing space for
those
that have undergone this kind of like
psychological crisis or spiritual crisis
spiritual emergency they are awakening
there isn't a container for them
um how can we support other individuals
that are in that kind of a state in that
kind of a
a context an internal context where they
don't know how to hold themselves as
they're expanding
they haven't found the right book or the
right teacher or the right whatever the
right
you know um context or container so
for me to approach it in a very infinite
way the cool one thing that is cool a
cool metaphor
is the um professor x's school right
you know in x-men yeah where he's just
like
each individual is is whatever it is
that they
they're going through whatever it is
their their superpower
that is the thing that is acknowledged
and totally yeah
and so to have something that is
broad in its catching but
supported in a way where you're able to
see
what the the individual is going through
personally so that does require
quite a lot of people yeah yeah um cool
a lot of
um individuals that have gone through
the experience themselves
so that they're coming from something
more ontological rather than mental
yes um beautiful another person like if
it's important you can only teach what
you got you can only teach
where you're at um yeah and so
and your client will can only get
what you get you know they will on some
level sense whether or not
[Music]
you're coming from a whole place or an
understood keep going i'll check i'll
check what's going on at the door
okay guys
[Music]
so yeah i mean i don't know whether or
not any any of you have experienced any
kind of a crisis whilst
you awakened or
experienced not having that kind of a
safety net to catch you as you went
through something that was expansive
or any experience that felt felt
overwhelming
um and in that in that scenario what
what did you do
what did you what did you how did you
help yourself
up and what was your catalyst you know
because a lot of the times the catalyst
is not going to be something that is
comfortable it's going to be something
uncomfortable
um very few are extremely lucky to have
had to have that kind of a very easy
and joyous and light trajectory
um into their expansion
thank you yeah yeah so what have you
guys been talking about
no nothing really really i'm i'm loving
the way you're just addressing the
audience we love you guys
yeah thank you yeah do let us know in
the comments about
like how to optimally architect this
where you're at
also in the process and maybe if you
write a comment one of us will come and
comment back with
some thoughts or even what your friends
have gone through
because there's there are there are um
do you have a youtube channel no
it's a sign that's a sign right she
totally needs it
she totally needs a youtube channel if
her if she decides that you know she
wants one
thank you but you you would rock yeah
thank you
oh yeah especially in the in the day of
more and more
desire civilizationally for spiritual
clarity
we need more people like at this retreat
to actually
have their own channels
and be posting on those channels and
yeah
it's actually like mission critical
component but some people here are like
they don't necessarily want to get on
the internet sphere which is their own
unique expression but other people
sometimes don't necessarily know that
they would be a [ __ ] rock star at it
and they haven't necessarily
played around with it so yeah but do you
have a
do you have an instagram or where should
people i have an instagram i've just
started making videos for that um
and so you can check that out at
sanyasaira
on instagram we'll put the link to her
instagram in the bio for you guys to go
follow her there is that the best place
for people to follow you
for now yes okay cool we'll put that
link in the bio what we talked about
with the densities was called the law
of one go look it up law of one
and
yeah and so how what kind of a what kind
of what was the question
what kind of container what kind of a
yeah what do we optimize
yeah exactly yeah basically and one of
the components was the one on one
and then we also identified that if
people do
are undergoing said process they can
potentially identify this
digitally and then
be sent somewhere physically yeah
and then physically there could be
experts
like what you described that have
already went through the process like we
were kind of talking about also in those
one-on-one scenarios people have had to
have went through somewhat similar
escape room dynamics
and then you know matching people up in
the physical setting those sound
very similar both like digital
one-on-one mentorship and also physical
window and mentorship
the space the space also has to be
something that is going to inspire
um and teach and so a lot of the natural
world is often that you know that
it's very metaphorical um to be in a
space like that rather than a white
cell you know and so
i would suggest that it would be
somewhere
beautiful absolutely beautiful um
as well as yeah for for this kind of uh
this kind of a space to be conscious in
that
people are supporting other people to
become the creator
in and not create a dependency on that
kind of a space
you know um because you want it to just
be a halfway house and and
and or like a trampoline where someone
cannot then create an identity and fix
themselves and say okay well i need this
space forever i'm gonna make a little
home here
but to in order to catalyze or to
to really support the awakening process
for it to be a very nourishing and
information
rich place but but what you simply want
is to reflect
back paradigms that are not serving the
person's awakening and
to offer an array of
of information or paradigms that do
support
and it doesn't have to just be one kind
of teaching because again we're infinite
expressions it can be that one
one individual will really resonate with
with sufism
will will want to go the sufi way you
know and that will be their natural
expression
and they may not have access to that
kind of teaching or a teacher some
people
learn really well from books some people
learn really well from other beings
um one on one and need that kind of a
contact need to meet their
master like okay wow that sounded
but you know what i mean like to
actually have a realized being in front
of them and that
that awakens something in them buffets
on both sides there's the buffet on the
side of the suffering
of how people wind themselves up in
those escape rooms
and then as they release themselves the
way they do so is by having the buffet
of options
on the other side of the awakening side
where
there are all these different ways paths
aphorisms books retreats
yogi's mystics that help
with the awakening and
many paths one end yet
at the same time there is a power law as
in
there are pointings that are
more efficient they're more optimal
they've gotten more people there faster
and so we got to take that into account
at the same time
yeah and that also i mean when you've
got people going from third to fourth
um a lot of the i think often if you've
got a being that is coming from
sixth or seventh that they will already
have learned
a kind a love style or no a more kind of
purified way of loving that is detached
and going from third to fourth um in
order to
you may not have the ability to perceive
love in the one that has
that has already learned um how to
how to purify themselves and love from a
purer place
because what you'll want if you will be
coming from scarcity
and lack and fear and all that and so
in order to be raised up
and excited by your awakening you may
need a bit more of a fourth fifth
density kind of
love loving energy in order to
yeah to support that step you know
and then to be able to understand that
there is love present in seventh even
though it may not be
what we have been programmed to perceive
love to be
yes you know and just to answer your
question again
it's the law of one and we'll we'll put
the link in the bio below to that as
well
for you to check out and we've done if
you want to just go look on our channel
for the seven
densities law of one video you can go
and see the map that we're talking about
right now
yes and probably a good way you're
welcome
probably a good way to wrap would be
twofold the first thing is that
the first thing is that wherever you're
at
right now especially if you're
in the transition from third to fourth
density if you're beginning to feel
like you want to get beyond suffering
and that you want to feel
this god this love love being god really
if you want to feel
love radiating from you like the sun
that one of the easiest ways
to do that is to become
aware of the fact
that you are aware and
practice in a sense doing things like
taking an object
and rather than seeing the object
itself become aware of the line
of perception okay so become aware of
the line of perception
and that even that might take you a
little bit of time to become aware of
the line of perception rather than the
object itself
and once you get really good at seeing
the line of perception rather than the
object then become aware
of seeing itself become aware of being a
witness or an observer or
awareness itself so not perception
but become aware of awareness or
witnessing or observing
and if you do those repetitions enough
you will then become more of
a awakened but you will also become more
of a watcher or a witness
to the clouds that arise in past so if
something does
occur like the story that might happen
that deals with your trauma or your
suffering
etc that you will have a
meta level of perspective
where you will no longer get absorbed
into the thought cloud
that arises but you will see that it
arose
and you will say that this is just like
what i was practicing with the water
bottle
so i'm just gonna do the same thing
where i focus on being an observer
rather than being attached to the water
bottle as an
object or as that traumatic story
that is then appearing and then
disappearing and as you get really good
at that
this is what buddha patanjali etc and
many of the mystic traditions taught
is that those clouds stop appearing
and so the as ramana maharshi says the i
thought disappears and that's when
you're
left with just the timeless
being the very timeless formless essence
that all of us share as the creator
and so that would be probably most like
just simple
practicality for being able to
shoot yourself out of suffering
by doing a very simple basic activity
that has been taught for thousands of
years and that we're now just trying to
modernize and and and disseminate to
people to
help catalyze that global awakening and
alignment so
okay so that was the first thing and
then the
second thing is that as we wrap
is what do you think is most
beautiful
are you asking me yes oh
from what from which
tier of consciousness shall i answer
that
um from
you know the the thing that comes
straight
for me is is just people
at the moment for me i really am
so appreciative of the reflections
and of the mirroring and of the
processes that we are going through as a
collective
the darkness that we experience the
resilience
um the this
pull it's the creator it is the creator
but
but just to be part of humanity right
um is so
rich and so
playful and divine and
and magical you know
i have a friend that that has a that
does gives talks and
he always says that we're in the age of
re-enchantment
yeah you know yeah it is yeah it's a
great way to put it
and that is that is such a beautiful
thing to be experiencing and
in order to be re-enchanted
you've got to have experience
disenchantment
you know and and we're we're going
through that we're going
from this disenchanted state into this
enchanted more more [ __ ] magical
yes place and yes on this perceived
timeline where we become
the creator we become what is permanent
we become what is
immovable
behind and beyond what
is movable what is transient
and that is it that is the one
end absolute nothingness
absolute infinity
both know self and all self
simultaneously so
accelerate yourself to the one end take
the steps that are needed we'll have
some links in the bio below for you for
the law of one material we were
referencing and also sonya's instagram
profile which you can go follow her
and that was a lot of fun yeah it was
[ __ ] yeah yeah that was beautiful give
what you got
you know if you've got something to
teach teach from where you're
at trust in your being and teach from
your being
perfect perfect we adore you
thank you thanks so much
super grateful if you guys found the
video useful
give it a like helps to algo subscribe
if you haven't
leave us a comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you
share the video with people that you
feel like it would resonate with
we adore you infinitely love to love
guys
thank you atlas thanks sonia one
infinite creator
expressing itself hey one infinite
creator express
in itself take one infinite creator
express in itself hey all right
adore you bye guys peace